What kind of high is it when you're on stage...
...and you look out and all you see are people?
I think it's like, you know, how people say...
...after you go on a stage...
...where you feel like you really interacted with the crowd?
It lasts for a long time and it's really addictive.
I totally experienced that this time.
So after the show, we drove back to LA...
...and we were at our hotel room, and I remembered...
...I just had to keep replaying it over in my head like again and again,...
...and it was like...
...that was the best feeling I've ever felt in my 22 years of existence.
It's really really surreal.
It's so life-changing.
I love the whole experience.
It's so beautiful and everybody is just amazing.
Everyone in the crowd.